a gente e hoje eu vim conversar com
vocês sobre crimes virtuais e uma
cirurgia porque não se sabia se sabia
enquanto vocês navegam na internet
digitando as pessoas alguém para
compensar isto vai conectar se estão
conectadas na hora
dificilmente a gente vai pensar nisso
vocês acham que o brasil possui
legislação adequada e capaz de
investigar e punir os malfeitores
virtuais que cometem os clientes é é
através da internet
bom
basicamente nós temos aqui um quadro
pois vocês uma linha do tempo para falar
em linhas gerais como é que anda a nossa
legislação no brasil
nosso código penal de 1940
em 2002 nós temos a obrigação do código
seguinte em 2012
né conta de eventos que levaram à edição
de uma lei que foi apelidada como legal
a minha dica que eu tive que ficar
alguns tipos de crimes que são cometidos
na incialmente através da rede mundial
de computadores e agora em 2014 nosso
querido famoso marco civil foi colocado
em que o então assim vocês vêem nessa
linha do tempo um lapso temporal muito
grande de 1940 até 2014
fora isso
o vaso que existem outras legislações
espaços que podem também vir a
influenciar é a questão da legislação
aplicável aos crimes virtuais e aí eu te
pego 0 pela legislação que tem esse
lapso temporal tão grande ela é efetiva
no combate ao crime virtual
eu torço pra vocês aqui necessário
basicamente alguns direitos e um chip de
direitos que podem vir a ser lesados ou
prejudicados com o as atitudes lícitos
que são pré convocados através de uma
navegação inocente uma pessoa comum até
mesmo em casos intencionais de
criminosos mesmo que nós a pegamos como
os criminosos virtuais
temos direito à vida a honra aos
segredos a património imaterial as
marcas a paz pública ao direito de
concorrência
a questão da pedofilia dentre muitos
outros
então eu vou falar pra vocês aqui sobre
alguns exemplos que aconteceram
recentemente que foram de ampla
divulgação que ajuda nos a passar a
começar a refletir se a nossa navegação
na rede está sendo feita de forma
responsável e seguro é recentemente
acho que em menos de um mês a foi
bastante divulgado essa questão do
aplicativo ciclo de alguns de vocês
tenha se instalado no smartphone
eu não tenho porque quando eu fiquei
sabendo do círio já tinha sido ordenada
a retirada da história e do dono da gol
também
basicamente é os leigos vem dando assim
o que você acha que foi certo tirado há
ou não a gente nós estamos diante de um
velho embate e direitos fundamentais
bastante interessante
por um lado nós temos o direito
constitucional à liberdade de expressão
por outro a mesma constituição que nos
dá o direito à liberdade de expressão
ela veda o anonimato porque ela vai dar
pra evitar que as pessoas sejam usadas
no seu direito à honra à imagem não
possam vir depois de se defender dessa
forma
essa decisão judicial que ordenou um
aplicativo na apple store do meia foi
uma decisão que gerou muita polêmica
muitas pessoas ainda discutem isso de
forma poderia ter sido feito para
minimizar o dano causado aquelas outras
pessoas que não tinham nada a ver com o
caso mas assim fica essa questão até que
ponto um direito fundamental pode se
sobrepor um ao outro
meu direito ao anonimato para garantir a
liberdade de expressão
o meu anonimato deve ser dado como
realmente fala a constituição e aí é
complicado você acredita honra e direito
das pessoas que se vê prejudicada suas
postagens anônimas por décadas passando
a outros visuais há outros casos esse
caso foi bem interessante porque uma
pessoa na sua utilização diária no
facebook
a pm polícia militar do município onde
mora não sabe ela é muito interessante
acostagem porque foi recente foi a gente
vê coisas assim não se viu tanto nesse
caso e eu aí essa celeuma
caso o problema é que ela fez uma
piadinha de assim de um pouco de baús né
publicou a imagem do cidadão sem
autorização dele ainda porque fez um
comentário tão bem pesado né e muitas
pessoas comentaram e fizeram comentários
até um pouco ele não gostou de ver
a senhora que a postagem em outra esfera
em outro nível de envolvimento e com a
internet
uma decisão judicial que a demissão por
justa causa
foi bom curtir uma publicação no
facebook e desaguava a empresa para
curtir
bom aí nós vamos entrar num nível um
pouco mais pesado digamos assim
eu tirei alguns comentários nesse conta
do facebook que tem publicação
com o advento de uma paga o nordeste
traz várias pessoas estavam no facebook
comentários
um tanto queria pesadas um tanto
inadequadas sobre a situação do nordeste
nem ele tem gente pergunta se não deixe
norte que folha de bananeira e dom
a pessoa fala sobre o apagão no nordeste
ninguém tem nada para ligar na tomada
por um ano
é desse nível aí pra baixo encontramos
freqüentemente não só com a nação não
deixem a gente mas tem pessoas do
público opiniões não tanto ofensivos
muito agressivas contra vários
documentos até minoritários né
vários menores que se vê vítima de
preconceito nas mais diferentes long
internet surgiu como mente você publicar
isso mundialmente navegar com
responsabilidade
muita gente parece que esquecem neste
ano a ses lembra do caso da maria
pedroso que ela foi ela fez um
comentário dessa natureza na internet e
acabou enfrentando um processo judicial
essa notícia desse dessas bandas
processo judicial a gente rodou o mundo
também o poder que a internet tem de
divulgar e disseminar
a volta também quando faz a questão não
é de fazer circular a notícia e mostrar
para o mundo que as pessoas não tanto de
olhos fechados para o que está
acontecendo outra cidadã ela pois é que
crianças
essa aqui bem presente uma lista o nome
de várias meninas que não
necessariamente tenha algo a ver com o
que está realmente acontecendo na
circulando na internet lá no estado
bailarino é simplesmente uma lista de
execução de prostitutas garotos de
programa
muitas das meninas não tem nada a ver
com isso está circulando no facebook mas
há basicamente fazer uma menor de 25
o impacto que uma divulgação errada
dessa natureza pode ter uma pessoa é
imaginado e às vezes as pessoas
compartilham coisas disco coisas sem
saber exatamente o que é que estão
fazendo sem pensar nas consequências
aqui está um exemplo pra vocês de como a
internet pode influenciar nosso direito
amiga como ela ultrapassa essa barreira
do fisco influenciar na vida de alguém
nesse caso extinguiu com a discussão
sobre práticas efetivas de praticar o
suicídio né
e aí a menina não satisfeita em pegar as
dicas de suicídio transmitir com as
pessoas sejam laicos colegas como
positivo pois é
e também como tráfico de drogas e desde
muito tempo esse exemplo é do nosso
senador cut
recentemente a união europeia decidiu de
navegar na internet não é eleitoral
então fiquem tranquilos quando você
estiver acessando o conteúdo que não
necessariamente têm a licença está a
partir da web não está obviamente isso
nós temos certeza que espanta temos o
lado do cartão 00
você pode encontrar várias dicas se você
resolver se pressionando para mim ou
digital na internet - e pega todas as
dicas e eu aprendi como fazer
quem nunca recebeu um e mail do banco
naquele meio falso você clica aqui no
link link na verdade vai funcionar com
uma coisa é falar coisas que você não
quer
e foi assim né que a cada unidade uma
perdeu aquelas fotos e acabou caindo na
internet
a confusão toda essa semana foram
divulgadas mais de 5 milhões de senhas
do gmail
você já verificaram na mente ativa pois
é
muitos incidentes de segurança
acontecendo e não gera nenhuma
preocupação
e aí gente o prato também algumas
decisões oficiais vão mostrar pra vocês
como que o nosso judiciário está lidando
com essas questões de tecnologia e meia
para o centro cada dia mas nas cortes
brasileiras nesse caso essa decisão
trata-se basicamente de um jornal que
tinha uma senha de administrador de
sistema e deu a senha de acesso não
colega não autorizada
ele teve sim mãe dele
andei por justa causa vale nada na
justiça porque não poderia compartilhar
senhas de atendimento de uso pessoal e
intransferível e agência trabalho
reconheceu esse caráter individual sem
validando assim a justa causa que foi
aplicada em caso de servidor público
também esse do mpf de são paulo
o código malicioso no servidor que pode
combinar a pena avaliá totalizaria quase
900 mil
bom esse aqui é assim porque o treino é
treino pelo que foi dito é um extremo a
condenação foi basicamente um cidadão
foi recebeu durante uma troca de e mails
de trabalho e de um superior eua
extremamente racista
essa situação e procurou ajuda tudo mas
fez nenhuma atitude
duzentos e sessenta e oito reais e moral
bem expressivo que pela natureza do dano
ou incompatível né gente escutar pra
vocês já está se movimentando no sentido
de identificar dois na internet
mas aí tinha uma dificuldade muito
grande que o marco civil b e acabou o
facilitar essa vida
nessa busca né pô identificar autores e
acabar co unidos de que vão bombar civil
se pauta por diversos valores
dentre o consentimento à privacidade e à
vida privada à honra não
compartilhamento de dados a proteção ao
consumidor a proteção ao usuário
dentre outros mas nesse aspecto
relacionado aos crimes virtuais a gente
teve importância à questão que foi
disciplinado de conexão e de acesso a
aplicações de internet nesse teu
disciplina o quanto tempo você guardar
dados o quanto com os provedores de
conexão quando da aplicação de internet
devem guardar essas informações e também
determinou links quais seja tem que ter
o respeito à intimidade à vida privada à
imagem das pessoas
mas havendo uma ordem judicial que
determine a o conhecimento dessas
informações na busca de identificar o
enfrentou efetivamente o menino se essa
essa disciplina de forma a une é
uniformizar como isso tem sido feito no
brasil que até então cada estado poderia
ser uma forma que com essa nova
realidade obviamente nós temos diversos
problemas de ordem prática que podem
inviabilizar uma investigação criminal
através de recursos de tecnologia e
principalmente na utilização da internet
mas com essa disposição legal
uniformizando minimamente tratamento que
estado é esse tipo de dado
com certeza teremos uma maior facilidade
na investigação de delitos na
identificação dos autores efetivamente
depois na sua devida punição
bom é isso que eu tinha
obrigada
meu muito obrigado